[Music]
nice - nice to finally meet you Frank
thanks for coming out to do this yes
amen you first came across I'm not like
a huge fight guy like I know a little
bit about MMA and I had a I think I've
had a couple fighters on the show before
well I'm friends with Mac Danzig who's
been on the show before but I think you
really kind of came on my radar when my
friend Ryan holidays book he goes the
enemy came out and the whole like
plus/minus equal theory which was
eloquently described in that book that
got me interested in you and your
background and then I saw you on our
friend James Altucher show who is the
person who connected us and in an
additional sort of cool little small
world is ambass a Bey that you did the
podcast with James right after that he
had Anthony Irvine on who you took a
picture with him who's a friend of mine
who's been on the show as well and he
was super stoked to meet you I know that
yeah that's cool I was in New York a
couple months ago and did James's show
and and Steve and his producer was like
you gotta meet Frank you got to meet
Frank so here we are man it's like to
talk to you so let's uh I think that
let's just start at the beginning man
you have a fascinating background and I
think above and beyond just your pure
athletic accomplishments work which are
extraordinary what I'm most interested
in is is how you overcame all the
obstacles that that you had to face
growing up and and even more than that
perhaps is how you've kind of channeled
what you've learned and the experiences
that you've had to benefit other people
so let's uh let's rocket yeah well um
let's see what I have now is a an
awareness of kind of what's going on and
what I realized as youth it's I didn't I
had no idea what's going course we don't
have any perspective zero and you grow
up in your environment that mine was
just jacked I mean it was completely
jacked unbeknownst to me mmm so all of
my talents and skills were just
completely wasted and just erratic
but as soon as I got into this martial
arts lifestyle and I started living and
kind of developing this way of
understanding how to live then
everything changed for me I had a whole
life I had all existence I had real
friends I had a family at real community
and before all that was not really in
existence it was just kind of this
fragile thing that semi existed so the
minute I became successful in a minute I
got stable you know I thought like gosh
we need to do something like we should
try to like flip this and help people
and that's what brought me into teaching
of the martial arts and kind of
developing that sight of my person and
that was like the best thing for me was
just teaching martial arts like
connecting with people through teaching
and because I was so passionate about it
because I was so you know in belief of
it that people you know they loved it
they followed me they learned they were
you know interested in it they were
compelled by it and it was a valued
study because at the end both we learned
how to kick everyone's butt you know and
create this amazing fighting system but
we also created this you know format for
living that's super successful right and
that's the plus/minus equal thing that's
right right right does that is that like
the core of like what is that blueprint
it's everything that happened to me and
my martial arts journey which is one day
I showed up at a martial art school and
I was taught like the basics of
discipline and respect and honor and
like those were as a young man the stuff
you see in movies and you're like oh
that's amazing but you don't really
believe it's true until you're bowing to
somebody and they're beating you down
and all of a sudden you're like wow
that's real stuff so we just all of
those sequential steps of this stuff
that I learned is this way that I call
the Warriors code the way I think about
things and that is you know if you it
doesn't matter what you approach it
doesn't matter business life social if
you you know if you enter it with
certain principles and ideas about
yourself and about the situation you can
do whatever you want with it you can
make it bad good you know you can
achieve your mission you
give it away do whatever you want but
none of that can exist without
understanding discipline and and really
harnessing willingness right like you
have to be willing to do the work right
can't bestow that upon an individual
that has to be a self-generated notion
that's all from inside that's all
personal and I call it divination I call
it the moment you go oh I'm an idiot or
oh I'm a but I'm ready I'm not that
whatever the decision is for me it was I
was sitting in prison I was like oh my
goodness I've I'm all those things they
told me I thought I was right there's
the honesty yeah it's like Oh will you
look in the mirror and really be honest
with yourself about where you're at as
opposed to fronting yeah and then
fighting it's so easy is you good to
face it on a daily right I'm and then I
got the most you know immediate you know
dose of humility you could possibly have
get immediate feedback daily okay that's
not working bad
yeah that's have not value and then when
you compete you get the same immediate
feedback both physically and then
socially mm-hmm what's amazing is that
you even you're even sitting here I mean
I agree you know like you were you were
Justin to become a statistic right and I
would imagine there's people even that
that had the fortuitous occurrence to
fall into a martial arts school after
having weathered something similar to
what you had to go through and still
don't make it out right so why do you
think you were able to to you know to
first of all be able to hear what was
being said to you to be honest with
yourself about where you were at and
then exercise the discipline to get to
work and rebuild your life I mean I
didn't hear it until the end yeah till I
was in prison and I was like okay I'm
doing the math no way yeah hey there's
literally no way like that was like what
about this or like you could have been
another criminal you hadn't just been in
and out you know my first stepdad Joe
was was this Irish dude and he was like
work it get it done and you know he
taught me I came from this hippie family
of whatever or do it we you know don't
worry about anything live off the
government
just kind of chill well let's go back
there I wanna I want to kind of really
understand you know those early years so
what was it like what was going on well
my um my mom had four kids by the time
she was 19 19 or 20 and she came from a
Jehovah's Witness you know community
which was basically her mom had run off
with the preacher at some point who was
a door-to-door guy and all of a sudden
she went from middle-aged you know
middle class you know wonderful going to
school existence to living in this you
know Jehovah's Witness culture were you
in the Bay Area then where was this um
this was in Los Angeles so I was born in
Santa Monica okay at the UCS UCLA
Medical Center and but then my mom moved
up north and she moved to Redding and
Anderson California which were like
small towns I'm assuming to get away
from the religion and get away from the
whole culture mm-hmm and then so I grew
up what my first memories were in red in
California which is like a small rural
town in central California and you know
we lived in the projects we were like
you know just welfare kids and then and
and so you know at some point it becomes
kind of a bit of a nightmare right like
abuse and you know getting locked in the
closet and all these things that you
know I read about as I sort of dug into
your story I mean you know it's
it sounds like horrific yeah yeah and I
didn't know any of this to me it was I
had a wake-up moment when I moved in
with our stepdad Joe you know I was like
eight or nine maybe I was eight and you
know I remember he him directing me in
the closet you know get in the closet
you know I remember the first
consciousness coming that he was putting
me in the closet unbeknownst to me I
found out thirty years later with my mom
my mom was since I was a baby putting
him in the closet and I was like this
thing you want to act out it will shut
you down right and it was very effective
were you the oldest or where'd you fall
I was the last two youngest uh-huh so I
have a younger sister and I have an
older brother that one older sister
mm-hmm
but yeah his last two youngest and I
don't know what the deal was I think I
had a law
of energy I think because of my
athleticism and stuff I think I had more
energy than others right now like
locking you in the closet so you know
shut it down so she could mini closet
and then how long after that before you
start kind of getting in trouble
it was about seven or eight I think it's
because my brain just turned on like all
of a sudden I was conscious and I was
conscious of these barriers and things
that were happening and and I see it
happening in my daughter she's now very
conscious she's nine and she's like
being she understands what's going on
now if I start locking her in the closet
she were like yo dad what if you do and
she'd be insane so it was right about
this time that I started just I couldn't
control myself emotionally it's like
seven or eight eight and a half and I
would just fall apart I would go to do
things like athletically or socially and
I would just have these you know social
breakdowns miss emotional breakdowns so
I I was seeing all these drinks and
therapists and like outside people to
help me and I nobody knew what was wrong
I didn't know what was wrong because I
didn't know that being locked in a
closet was not normal right so when
they're saying what's going on at home
you're like what are in the closet did
the shrinks come in because of school or
young boys I'd have these breakdown
right school and I was excelling like
I'd be getting straight A's but then to
be some you know confrontation or some
physical moment that I couldn't come
physical deal with I freaked out right
and so they mites that are lights yeah
yeah people picked on me because I was a
victim of abuse I give you picked on me
I would freak out mm-hmm you know cuz I
didn't want to be abused so about my
buttons just getting pushed in your yeah
acting yeah yeah yeah yeah and I was
very young so I didn't know you know I
just knew that when it was time to
defend you know you just went all right
you went all in but that's interesting
you were a good student though
nonetheless yeah they're like silly
smart yeah I could I read all the books
I went home I was like a super nerd I
went home I read all the books all right
I you know I would show up in class I
knew everything you know I was there was
the kid disrupting the class because I
had nothing to do at home
uh-huh yeah there was no TV there was no
social interaction so I went home I read
the whole book right
so when did when does when you get into
scruffs with the law that was about 909
yeah what line shoplifting yeah shoplift
I would shoplift a lie would you know go
into a store and drink alcohol in the
back like I would steal things stealing
he think like looking back on that now
is that was that some form of a cry for
help like like an unconscious desire to
like yeah and I think a push back on the
the stuff you know it wasn't like it
wasn't normal it didn't feel good yeah I
didn't feel good I felt good stealing
things right I felt good about that like
I was totally fine uh-huh yeah yeah I
got this stuff and then I get in trouble
and be like but that's so wrong uh-huh
because I really felt okay GUP fell okay
yeah that's how messed up things were I
mean in in the in the household so
you're getting locked in a closet I mean
was the was there some physical abuse
sexual like what was it what was this
but an overabundance of emotions and
people freaking out and you know you get
hit kneel in the hallway for hours
you know Joe had us kneel in the hallway
we kneel on your knee and put your put
your nose on the wall for like four
hours in the hallway and then the word
discipline yeah the world would go on
around you and you just be kneeling in
the hallway and like if you sat down on
your heels you'd get screamed at uh-huh
it was like a whole you know and he was
you know the poor guy went to Vietnam as
a young man you know fought his heart
out and came back and everyone hated it
yeah he turned out yeah you don't
Eamon's you don't yeah you don't you
don't treat your family that way yes I
was reeling in the hallway when I was
like nine years old you know thinking
about my punishments and you know and
coming from a from a family before that
that was without a father without
leadership and the mom was like do
whatever you want we're hippies you know
we you know have fun
it just completely you know made me you
know push back I was on and did your mom
how did your mom survive that like how
is she around now yeah yeah mom still
life she's in East Texas
jaelyn so all right so your shoplifting
yeah stealing food god it's at some
point though like juvenile hall kind of
enters the picture yeah yeah yeah well I
eventually stolen some weed from my
neighbor's pouch on his ten-speed
because I knew that he was selling
kisses but the younger brother told me
and we ended up getting arrested at the
pond or park or something but I got 11
days that yeah I got 11 days of juvenile
hall mmm and that was the first time
that I got taken away from my family and
yeah and that was the first time where I
was like talk to other kids about you
know what was going on these were all
the bad kids right so I was like ah bad
kids how we do it I was checking in and
giving him you know here's what's
happened and they were like are you
kidding me like oh yeah I read somewhere
yeah we you don't get locked in a closet
like you're not living in the backyard
and a tarp and they're like what it was
they're like what are you talking about
and it was the first time when I was
like I had no idea that that that wasn't
happening to other kids right and that
they were you know she's you're normal
that was my normal and is that is that
when you kind of got the speech about
hey listen if you keep getting into
trouble you're gonna have to live here
all the time and you thought well that's
the sound say yeah yeah yeah it was
either and I'll never forget it they
were like this and if you continue to do
this we'll take you from your home mm-hm
and I was like ah that's sound thank you
like wow think what do i what do I need
to do and then they followed up with if
you continue to do stuff exactly like
this I was like this is amazing I know
exactly what to do I was 11 11 11 years
old yeah I think they now call that the
the school to Prison Pipeline yeah I was
like you you are on a turbocharged ride
right in the heart of that yeah so how
long do you end time do you end up
spending throughout your youth in juvie
I went in and out so I went from the
crisis center to foster care
to youth youth home to group home and
then to work camp and then to youth
prison was kind of my journey right and
so how old were you at that point so I
was 13 when I got to youth camp uh-huh
which was one step before youth prison
right and so what you know paint me the
picture like what's that what's a
day-in-the-life and in that experience
all about it just I was I was young kid
had no idea what's going on and they
were just moving from place to place and
I'd meet new families and they were nice
like they were but you know at that time
it was a religious based community that
was kind of supporting that side of
social services
uh-huh so it was Christian Science and
it was Mormons there's all these
wonderful families and I'd show up and
just train-wrecked him I felt so bad in
hindsight but I was just traumatized so
I try to fit in I try to figure it out I
try to you know integrate and then
something would happen I'd freak out
emotionally and I'd break you know I'd
escape I'd steal something I steal a
call right steal the van I take
everybody in the group home right I
would do something just completely
jacked to make sure that they would come
get me and move me to the next place and
then each time it would be it would
escalate in insecurity and increase in
and you know lack of resources or lock
up you know resources and each time it
would be closer to you know what I
realized in prison yeah
were you getting like any kind of
psychiatric or psychological help along
the way cuz clearly like this pattern is
emerging and you need help like you need
somebody to talk to and they're just
kind of shuffling you about right hoping
for the best when they're not they're
not nobody's actually confronting like
there's no making you behavior
there was no resources for them and
there was that was thrown back on the
families you know they were providing
that support you know to kind of be
families right so all right so playing
it forward then what you know how does
this play out like you're basically you
just you're in this cycle of like
increasingly you know worse and worse
situations in terms of your behavior but
like you know where are you at 18 years
old and you know what's going on at that
point
well when I was 16 and a half my son was
born
and then within within six to eight
months I was in prison jail and started
going on to the kind of youth prison
thing um would you do that time oh man I
was stealing stuff just it was just a
wreck of it like it was just a regular
human stupid [ __ ] yeah and it was it
was just about being a wreck of a human
being like it wasn't about anything like
it wasn't making money or just being you
know as bad as I could be for whatever
reason mm-hmm and so yeah of 17 I got
arrested for stealing a bunch of stuff
and then I went to youth jail and then
they put me in jail afterwards and then
basically like listen you're 17 you're
an emancipated minor you're married
because you you're an emancipated minor
and you're gonna be tried as an adult
so all this from moving forward is gonna
be adult time adult actions and adult
commitments and then and I thought they
were like the same old stops like hey
whatever you know and I wasn't like oh
[ __ ] just got real
oh yeah it wasn't real until I was in
prison for about a year and I did all
this stuff and wrote all the things told
all the stories and I was like you wait
man they're serious like I'm not gonna
get out for you know another two and a
half years so what prompted you to start
kind of journaling and and getting real
yourself it was my son's birth it was
him being born I'd never had a father
like I just never had anybody there and
then Joe came along but it was weird
nabis Ariel and I wasn't like connected
to the Father Ness and I wasn't until I
was in my you know from when I was 13 to
15 that I had a dad you know Bob
Shamrock came along and I was like I've
got this father figure so my son was
born I was like this is my only chance
to influence his life and be a dad like
this is it and I'm in prison I was like
that's like all this stuff that just
happened to me and I could do that I
have to change that you're just gonna
repeat I was it I go to hey what am i
doing I'm like I'm the I'm my dad and I
was like so I just I opened up the
notebook and I was like no I go how do I
change it and first it was how do I get
out of it
because that was what I was taught and
that didn't work so then it was how do I
take responsibility and figure it out
and move forward it's interesting that
you decided to just start writing like
where do you think that impulse came
like just there was nothing else to do
or like this is the only thing that you
actually have control over is to start I
think because it's my first voice I
think is my first communications they
were real as I was writing down what was
real in the beginning it was just all
the horrible stuff that was happening
what am I gonna do and and then it was
how do I get out of these things and
then it was you know real plans and then
it was legal writs how do I get out of
this you know with the law and I use the
rest of it but I also we know once I sat
there for a year and I was like I'm not
getting out like nothing I can do say
there's no because before I could show
up I could dazzle um I'd be listen I was
locked in closets you don't understand
how terrible it's been and I'd be like
well that's really terrible you know we
should help you and after about you know
four years of that people were like now
you know you've stolen everything done I
you're not you say what you say you are
so it became my responsibility to say to
be what I said I was and I'm sorr
whatever I wrote down I was like I'm
gonna be that dude hmm I'm gonna go to
school I'm gonna do the thing I'm gonna
be honest like I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna
tell the thing yeah me but there had to
be like there was an impulse inside of
you that was telling you like I'm not
this guy I don't need to continue down
this path I mean I think a lot of for a
lot of people probably I would imagine
most people that system just breaks them
down and then they're just I'm a piece
of [ __ ] and this is what my life's gonna
be like and they just sort of you know
wave the white flag and and just take it
you know but there was something inside
of you that that had a vision for a
different life yeah and a part of it was
I would see my friends come and have the
same friends they were at the beginning
of the cycle and we'd all be in prison
together and be like whoa it's like it's
happening to him - mmm it was like it's
it's right there and I could see it and
it became the example of like this is
what you're not supposed like you're not
supposed to do this right you'll be so
done and then you know I had somebody
hey Bob shamrock yeah you had Bob so you
met Bob earlier right yeah and I was 13
or 12 almost 13 I went to his group home
uh-huh and so he was taking kids in and
he was training people to be fighters
and now that's not wine or athletes yeah
but he did have that ritual if you had
beef with somebody you dealt with it
mm-hmm and that was in the swimming pool
right you know yeah you literally put
the gloves on and everybody stood in a
circle and then you went at it and then
you can talk it out and now the rule was
that when it was over you hugged it out
it was over uh-huh
so when you were there when you were 13
yeah how many kids were there at that
point 20 21 22 it's kind of amazing that
he was all boys like what I mean what
compelled him to you know begin doing
that he was those were his kids you know
he couldn't have kids and his wife tried
and you know he was deeply religious and
you know he grew up in LA you know his
dad had a textile mill and business was
very successful and they you know he saw
downtown you know in the homelessness
and he always wanted to help that
community so we couldn't have kids he
was like these are gonna be my kids I'm
gonna start at home I'm the help of the
kids mm-hmm and originally they were
just gonna be you know the kids they
were gonna adopt them they weren't gonna
you know make him family family right
but you know when his marriage fell
apart and his wife left you know that
became his family and we brought him his
family yeah that's amazing so you have
that experience so nervous he was crazy
giant family and a huge van it was the
craziest thing you know you could
imagine we're like the wild boys uh-huh
but it was all with the goodness like
you know we would clean up the parks
like we would play the football team we
would play the cops you know we were he
believed like through athletics and
three like family and like you know
accomplishment like you could you know
really do anything like you could build
anything so when you're when you finish
with prison how do you end up back with
him like did he come and get you he
never left so he always advised me and
he always
visited and wrote me and sent me you
know money and encouragement and you
know you know kept track and you know
and he also advised me yeah he was the
one who was like what are you gonna do
are you gonna do and I was like I don't
know I mean I what about God the only
thing I got is this body you know I
built up this body I've done this thing
and because he really believed in
athletics and bodybuilding and you know
he's guided me on that path so I spent
those three and a half years in prison
you know super nerdy now on bodybuilding
and lifting weights so by the time I got
out like I was 220 a solid all-natural
you know how much like no time if you
have like could use workout all day or
like huh yeah I mean you get it you get
by law I've got some super nerd by law
you get an hour a day if you're in
beneath maximum-security so I got an
hour a day minimum but I would get three
and four hours a day plus I would always
work in the kitchen so I made sure I
could have the calories to support what
I was doing and I was working out you
know hour and a half two hours a day six
days a week so like an hour in the yard
but then back in your cell also push-ups
and that kind of thing or I didn't do a
lot of extra like calisthenics stuff at
that time until I got into my minimum
security stuff and I was running like a
fire crew and like a whole other team in
the beginning I just lifted weights like
cuz I was also in level four I mean
Charles Manson was like one yard over
when I first got went down I was like 18
years old I got the Corcoran they're
like yeah Charlie's over there I was
like what but I just lifted heavy until
you know for three years and then when I
got to minimum security and then that
kind of changed my whole structure but
what I would do was I would stretch
I would always stretch and try to keep
myself limber mm-hmm cuz I was packing
on muscle it just went right it was
crazy
mm-hmm all you do is sleep and read and
and lift weights and write walk around
the yard and flex your muscles like
nothing and I would imagine there's a
lot of energy going into you know
alliances just survive right yeah who
you hanging out with who's watching your
back whose back are you watching like
all that I mean
my only you know frame of references
what I see in movies and on television
or other people that I've had on the
podcast but yeah yeah I forgot to take a
psychic toll yeah it's real and I mean I
grew up alone obviously you know with
him without family so and then when I
went when I first went to jail like I
didn't know that I was brown it's gonna
mean like what grey everybody around me
my wife my mom my mom everybody was
white so I thought I was kind of white
and then when I first went to jail they
were like listen man you can't just be
hanging out with white people like
what's your race and I go everyone
around me is white you're Brown so in
the beginning they were like you're
Mexican
I was like I don't know man and I don't
really like we're not like Mexican
whatever so when I went to prison I was
encouraged to hang out with the Mexicans
and I was like I'm not Mexican so I
wouldn't hang out with the Indians with
others because they're of a culture
that's just you know whatever you are
you are if you're Hawaiian you're
Polynesia and you're Indian you're in
that group mm-hmm
and that I think made it a little bit
easier and a little bit more challenging
for me when I was doing time because I
was easily attacked in that group
because there's not a lot of power and
there's not a lot of strength in that
group uh-huh I can't imagine man I mean
it's it's just so crazy that you got
through that you know and then
ultimately end up with Bob and you come
out to 20 what you were jacked up I was
I was - I was probably - 18 - 18 - 18
you're on five ten uh-huh just all
natural just a huger than huge and um
you know when I got out Bob Bob picked
me up and he basically gave me this this
super dad she pep-talk
he's like listen you've you've screwed
up your life but he's like he just made
this huge commitment and he lined off
all these things I did when I have some
prison is like you got educated you went
to college
you know you've lifted weights right you
went to college in prison I went to
college in prison I got all these things
and he's like an you know you could fix
sheet metal and cars and because I was
like a super nerd I was locked up I was
like I'll take everything I'll do
anything to get out of here you know cuz
I didn't realize I was screwing up until
I screwed everything up and then I was
stuck and then I was like oh hell no and
I was gonna get
but you know he's like listen you you
could you could be an athlete he could
be a performer you could do this you
know and by the time my brother had just
had a successful career as a stripper
right so he's Liz's Ken right yeah so
he's like you could be a stripper like
your brother he's like he made a ton of
money he tells me the whole story and
I'm like okay he's like or your
brother's also doing this wrestling
thing now and it's totally taken off and
it kind of breaks it down to me and it
makes it sound like it's sport wrestling
grappling fighting right and I'm like
okay so I get out I have two days out
and then the second day he drops me off
at the dojo and it's like you know he's
like what are you gonna do and I got I'm
gonna be a fighter I'm not gonna be a
stripper right that can't
that's ridiculous just for clarity than
good short-term cash you know yeah this
huge long hair so I mean I totally I
could see where he was coming like the
Chippendales yeah I can see where the
where the money was coming from but I
was like I don't you know can't do that
I can't do that I just not mean and and
so just for clarity Ken is Bob's adopted
son who then becomes your adopted
adoptive brother and Hearst mob adopts
you yeah right yeah and then first
teacher and trainer right for fighting
and and it seems like this all happens
pretty quick Yeah right so you go to the
dojo and was it immediately like this is
my home um no it took me a long time to
get adjusted to it because I think
because I just come from prison so I had
this very close you know I was living in
books and the special world and working
out all day and flexing on the yard and
living this other existence that's a
very sub world and then when I got into
the fighting thing it's a whole other
sub world we there's no time to do
anything else like you just focus
everything on the thing and then you're
always tired and exhausted so I just
tried to show up like an and like not
die and I think people appreciated that
and then I think people were turned off
by it cuz I yeah it looked like a tough
guy but I didn't know anything mm-hmm
so they would just beat me up and you
know I was I was a waste of space when I
first
because I look like I could head value
but ahead you're walking around like you
know you got a deal but you it's not
like you were a wrestler in high school
no I did nothing
yeah you made more than like two days of
wrestling camp and I get thrown out by
getting some fight or something terrible
would happen or some you know emotional
breakdown or something ridiculous so
yeah I never made a sport longer than a
week
and so what kept you in what was it just
this is the only thing that was going
yeah that was it it's this or nothing
was it that's all I had you know and I
thought okay wait I could get out and I
could use these sheet metal you know
certifications that I got or I could go
do this thing that I got never have that
thing like I've never and my thing was
my dream was to be a world champion you
know my dream you know there was a few
moments of my life where I remember
complete clarity and those divin nations
where I was like this is what I'm gonna
be when I become who I want to be and
that was watching boxing at the foot of
my stepdads bed and watching him fight
and win and then you know be a champion
and then deliver a moment you know and I
have everyone be focused on that moment
and like I just remember that and I was
like I'm gonna be that guy so you had
you held that vision even though you're
getting your ass yeah I need when I was
in prison even all through this journey
of life were that living in the streets
I eating at a track all this stuff I was
like you don't understand someday and it
was deep like there was no effort
towards it until I got out of prison so
we don't make of that I mean where does
that where does that come from
I mean I think a lot of people would
just be like you know my life's gonna
this is my life and it sucks but yeah I
think if you never give up on that thing
then it's totally worthwhile but to even
have the idea to begin with but
everybody has yeah right everyone has
the idea you think so yeah I asked my
daughter in the mornings what do you
dream about and she tells me mmm and
there's this said they're the same
dreams she wants to be next to zendaya
dancing and singing and do you know
hitting the movements on Disney Channel
because
in her world that's where she got
inspired so it's like it all she wants
for me is to create that right but get
me NASA's India because your support has
you saying well let's let make this
happen right whereas you get you have
the world beating down on you yeah but I
also developed and got into this system
and martial arts was the first one right
you know martial arts was the was the
family so when you hit that dojo are you
thinking well I'm gonna even though
you're getting your butt kicked like I'm
gonna make a career out of this I'm
gonna find a way to make money or I mean
you must have thought well I can go do
this and learn I'm getting my ass kicked
like I gotta make some cash like maybe I
should do this sheet metal thing on the
side or get something else going on I
honestly thought it's all there was
because I also knew like who's gonna
hire me I'm gonna have like 24 felonies
like you know it's like ridiculous like
there's no I have no real qualifications
for anything other than teaching people
to be people up and helping inspire
people the thing is like there's there's
something so powerful about just being
all in yeah you're just all there is no
other route there's no plan B like this
is what I'm doing even though like I'm
just learning and I don't know what I'm
doing I'm getting my ass kicked
like I'm here yeah what I think that's
what the beauty of the whole system is
and how it works it's like when you show
up mmm like when I show up and I'm and I
humble myself to a mentor you know who
sometimes has been I've been a fan of or
they've been a fan of me or like there's
all kinds of roles that we play but to
show up to a plus and to be like listen
man all I'll clean your floors do you
like show me the thing and I'll I'll
I'll be over here you know so right yeah
you have to you have to have that
humility Yeah right
does did you learn that humility through
fighting or through just life experience
I learned it through the fighting yeah
because it's it's the I learned
everything on the example and everything
on the real as I call it so it's like
how do you figure out what's bad do all
the bad stuff and they'll send you to
prison you'll get
I can tell you exactly what's bad they
well ng up in person conversely I can
tell you exactly what's good but it's
only through the experience of doing um
but here's the thing once you once you
have people that have done the
experience you don't really have to go
on the journey you can find somebody who
hey buddy what's funny is that you're
like this bookish nerdish nerdy kid he
was like it academically inclined is
reading all these books like you could
have learned these lessons you know on
the written page but you have to have it
you had to experience it for yourself
yeah but I think it's because my social
and family situation was so
dysfunctional yeah so it gets worse when
realities backwards then you do the
backwards oh yeah so you mean it's
almost like if it was a there was a
vacuum of free well like you were headed
in that direction until something
intervened so alright so you're you're
you're you're learning you're in the
dojo your your training your butt off so
you know where does the first fight come
up like you I mean you hit the ground
running it seems let me just say way the
way it reads online it's sort of like
this just kind of happened overnight it
did it did
partly because I mean I took me like two
weeks to heal up from the tryout because
Ken the tryouts I can sane you do 500
squat sit-ups push-ups and leg lifts and
then you spar a professional fighter for
20 minutes and mine was Ken because he's
like well I'm gonna he's my brother I'm
gonna do him right you know honor she
and he just beat the hell out of me and
it took me a couple of weeks to recover
and in that time I just you know I
accepted what I was accepted what I was
going to do to the to the max of what I
understood so I you know during those
two weeks I changed my mind I mean okay
I'm I'm jacked up but I'm gonna become a
professional fighter and this is my
chance so I'm gonna go all-in
mmm-hmm and and as soon as I healed up I
just started training and taking notes
and I took the same mindset that I had
in prison which was I was I was needing
to overcome this thing you know I was
stuck it was trapped because I didn't
have and and this was the path mm-hm and
I just I followed the path I showed up
every day I studied I was you know I
created theories and ideas and con
subs and I asked questions and they beat
me up because I asked questions because
it was you know there was a culture
before that we didn't ask questions
right he followed them you follow the
rhythm and the flow and the thing and
the curriculum and so I was unbeknownst
to me against a system a little bit and
a bit abrasive they beat about some more
like right learn because you know
normally you know you you want someone
to stop by his question is beating what
a few times and they stopped asking
questions but for me I was so used to
getting beat up cuz I didn't know
anything and it was all part of the
journey that I was just like I'll fully
accept that haha it's like getting a
spanking when you like doing something
when you know you're gonna get a
spanking with it right I would do that
right because I knew like I'm gonna get
the answer are part of it and then a
beating and I'm like that's alright I'm
totally worth that and you're like I
know how to do the beating part I can
survive I'm super strong but kind of
what I infer between the lines with this
is is like this deep sense of personal
responsibility like yeah you have Bob
and now you've cannon and you've got
this community at the dojo
but this understanding like the only
person who's gonna be able to solve this
dilemma of life that I'm in is me and
and the only way out of this situation
to a better life is through and I have
to rely on myself and my own you know my
brain and my body and my mind and my
spirit and and and and within that like
this idea of just doubling down like
going all in completely and and resting
all the responsibility for that path on
yourself
is that fair yeah well I mean I think
it's the only way
mm-hmm I think you'll find Buber
successful people in sports and
everything else have the same mindset
Drive you know persona or whatever
whatever you want to call mine was from
a place of desperation and survival and
and all the other stuff but well many of
my other friends you know it comes from
a place of competitiveness and you know
self achievement and community
achievement so on the competitive aspect
of it
do you see yourself as somebody who is
competing or at least at that time like
competing against others to be better
than other people or was it more of an
internal thing like competing against
yourself to be the best version of you
it was both for me because I was also
leading the sport or trying to lead the
sport so you know everyone was
eventually studying me and and it was
also based on survival mmm so like I had
to win
like I always had to win right because I
was also going with the notion of like
I'm gonna fight to the death
so therefore I have to win because you
know I'll exhaust all remedies so I had
this you know always super intense
intensity about my competition and then
yeah I'm sure of that came from
internally you know is that oh you know
all I ever wanted was that thing it's
really mean and imagine having it right
there and all you gotta do is beat
somebody up or I could just work really
hard or all you got to do is you know
really truly apply yourself and for
whatever reason you know God the world
Bob it was all laid out in front of me
and I just had to achieve it you know go
down the journey so how long before from
the first moment that you walk into the
dojo to your first competitive fight 8
months 8 months and what happened in
that fight I won IB IB bas Rutten yeah
and in 10 minutes by decision mm-hmm
technically and and it was just
instantly I went from nobody to super
stuff suddenly so great I mean how how
did you get such a prestige fight right
out of the gate like that didn't you
have to it would seem like you'd have to
work your way up to a fight like that
well pancrase was a fairly new
organization it kind of gone through the
first cycle of stars so they were
looking for a new kind of generation of
stars and we just all happen to come
along in this new tournament mm-hmm I
was made to build the next wave of stars
and boss was like my counterpart Ken and
I was Ken's brother in the US and he was
boss friend he had these you can write
short end is a like a grudge match kind
of thing
he hadn't beaten can yet they hadn't
matched up yet I don't think
but he'd knocked down a ton of people
and he was very danger I didn't know he
was I came out of nowhere
I'm like a young nerd from prison every
time I ask somebody have honey bas
Rutten they're like oh and they would
look down at the ground I believe this
is just terrible yeah but there's
something great about that naivete like
when you don't know yeah inside it's
horrifying because yeah but how did you
know and had you been able to fully
appreciate the situation you were in you
know the fear might have gotten the best
of you yeah but in hindsight it's
horrifying because I just wrestled this
past New Year's in Japan and like this
kind of crazy grappling match and I saw
that generation that I was 20 years old
no no no idea what's going on the fear
and the all that stuff going on I was
like I can't believe I did all that like
I can't believe I went through that and
and came out like you know halfway okay
like that's insane
so speaking of Japan when do you you end
up going to Japan was it after that
fight or before well that fight was in
Japan I was in my message I think 16
fights were in Japan but you you so you
lived there for a while though right
yeah why went there so after six months
of training I moved to Japan uh-huh and
then I finished my training in the
Japanese dojo right and training what
was the style of fighting that you were
learning there Pancrase or what they
would call submission submission
fighting submission grappling style hmm
and was that different than what was
going on in the States like why did you
go to Japan that's where the money was
and that's where the developed leagues
were you know we were on a gang of 20
city tour and and then that's where the
contacts were that's where the
opportunity was in the States it was
still like UFC was just about started or
just had started and it was a tiny
audience that was doing good numbers on
pay-per-view but it was nowhere near the
revenues that were we're coming in Japan
at that point yeah and and what did you
learn kind of about being immersed in
that culture that helped you as a
fighter or as a human uh I actually
learned a lot because I you know if you
if you position that
since I just came from prison like I was
missing in prison for three and a half
years and before that I was a complete
criminal like living on the streets and
he's doing everything horrible you could
ever imagine
so I it was this weird moment where I
went from the fear and quietness of
prison and the focus to this other fear
and quietness in Japan because I've
never left the country like I've never
done anything like this in my life and
all of a sudden I'm on parole going to
live in Japan and finish my martial she
had like did you have to clear that is
the greatest letter writing of my life
like I had to prove that it only exists
in Japan it's an emerging Spore the
revenue like there was all this you know
preparation and stuff my my my skills
you know after person were put to good
use but yeah I went to I went to Japan
on parole and finished my career of
training and it was just it was a crazy
wake up because no one spoke English hmm
so every day was it was the same
quietness that was in prison but it had
this whole other intensity because I was
gonna fight this guy I knew I was gonna
fight the guy the minute I landed like
you're gonna fight the guy and I was
like oh okay so it was all leading to
this moment it was a very intense you
know two and a half months where
everything was just every single day I
was like oh my gosh oh my god it's
coming and I'd be like who you fighting
they bas Rutten and they'd look down and
I'd be like this is the whole like I'm
so scared and then luckily Funaki and
Tsuzuki the older teachers of the dojo
basically Ken's role for us in the
States
you know they they took me under their
wing and they showed me the basic stuff
and yeah they basically saved my life as
I see it because I was not prepared to
fight bas Rutten when I when I landed in
Japan mm-hmm he's gonna kick my face
right but you it's somehow you you you
you beat this guy
I don't know how you did that but you do
and and you know you're launched into
you know immediately into mainstream
awareness as the this new talent right
and and as I understand it you were kind
of looked at as somebody who could excel
in all the various disciplines of mixed
martial arts right like I
a triathlete like my analogy to that
would be you know in the in the sort of
earlier days of triathlon there'd be the
guy who was an amazing runner in college
and then you didn't really know how to
ride a bike or swim but he could he was
doing really well because he's really
good at one of those three things but
today as the sport has matured you have
to be you have to be amazing at all
three of them or you're out right and
yeah and so when I was reading about you
I was thinking well you were you were
kind of like one of the first guys who
was who could who could excel across the
board and all the many different kinds
of styles of fighting and disciplines
that are required to excel in MMA so
yeah that totally yeah I was the first
complete athlete mm-hmm because that's
where the study took me mm-hmm
the need was to create a system ala
Bruce Lee we need to the most amount of
damage with the least amount of effort
to yourself and you could win under the
skill set under the rules so the rules
were ever-evolving as was the athlete in
the sport I was the first like super
athlete hmm that could fight I only say
could fight because I had more
techniques than the other super athletes
and then I was the first guy to put a
whole system together where I was good
at punch kick wrestle knee you know
position 11 of my last 11 fights all
finished differently because it doesn't
matter where you're from or what
position you're in
everything has equal damage opportunity
if you have the right system and this
system that you put together was this
something that you crafted yourself like
as part of the like hey I have a new
idea or a different idea or is this
something you learned from the Japanese
pure survival it wasn't an amalgamation
of everything it happened so as a sport
continued to evolve in the last seven or
eight years of my career I was focused
solely on striking because the five
years before the sport was focused
solely on grappling so a lot of the
focus turned somewhere else so I turned
my attention elsewhere to develop my
skill elsewhere right but it was about
staying ahead of the sport and staying
ahead of the development and the the
popularity curves in the sport and in in
trying to stay ahead I just put together
a complete system because I kept facing
everybody and their skill would be
somewhere else and then
would be somewhere else mm-hmm and at
the end of I'd say 15 years I had a
complete fighting system that would you
know stand up to any any system any
martial art any adjusted martial art
right so grappling striking on the mat
no matter what it is like yeah you're
able to like man anyway right yeah and
at that time was it true that like most
of the fighters were they would be good
at one of these things but you always
knew what their weakness was yeah and
you could kind of exploit that to your
benefit
because in the beginning it was singular
martial arts mmm it was you know I'm a
karate guy or I'm a wrestler and I'm
gonna use that skill set as a base you
know to to gain control right yeah and I
would just study I didn't know any
better you know to me I didn't know you
what you weren't not supposed to do or
what your system was supposed to have I
had no rules oh that was just surviving
I think so every other systems like
don't go to your back Wow Oh your back
um I'm on my back you know if it's
easier to move I'm gonna go there so I
just rewrote and wrote my own system and
I used all the strengths of the other
martial arts that were around me and
that often times were being tested
against me mm-hmm
so a lot of these martial arts skills
that I learned where I'm gonna fight so
and so they're really good at this
well we'll study that what does that
mean and then we'd figure out new stuff
around that mm-hmm
and we'd add that to the system yeah
interesting now go out and kick their
butt and write them like well it works
right right right
we keep it in the system right and and
within that is kind of an appreciation
for really trying to figure out what
your own personal weaknesses are right
and focusing on developing them as
opposed to well I'm a I'm a striker I'm
a grappler so I'm gonna double down on
that because that's what I know how to
do but instead to say well here's where
I can develop where I'm weak that would
make me this super athlete and be able
to perform in all the various you know
capacities that I need to to go to the
top yeah that's the harder journey yeah
that facing all the week no one was
worried
let's show all the work on our
weaknesses today yeah but that's the
real stuff you know that's what that's
what they really do right you know and I
was it I would just have guys it'd be
like before we knew
you know I just protect listen put me in
the wall put these gloves on punch me in
the head what are you talking about I'm
like well I got to figure this out
nobody's got a theory I was like so
punch me - had a few times and like I'm
gonna work this out like you're insane
epic but somebody's got to figure this
out so rather than like finding the
coach who knows how to do that you're
just gonna you know figure it out on
your well I also figured out nobody knew
mm-hmm
because once I started my journey and I
started teaching and I started sharing
and I started giving because I thought
that was the natural process to learn
more you give more mm-hmm I started
realizing people didn't know right
and I started people people would blow
up and interrupt and you know change the
information I'd be like wait a minute
how do I get out of the wall when
someone's punching me in the head like
that's all I need to know right right
but they would be distracted by other
things because everyone what I realized
that was really weird
is I was just on a journey to survive
and you know it was changing martial
arts at the same time yeah yeah that's a
lot of resistance in all sports and all
martial arts about the whole thing
mm-hmm
cuz no one knew what was going on and it
was so new and different right it was it
was so different back then to what it is
now so when you look at the sport today
and you see these guys are like I mean
the money aspect aside in the media
aspect aside like what's different about
the guys that are fighting right now
like what's different about Conor
McGregor vs. you know what was going on
when you were competing no nothing
yeah in order to win now they all have
to be super I'll yeah no no I mean the
here's the beauty of fighting and I
think it holds true in some other sports
everything works when you're a super
athlete hmm everything works you hit
somebody and you're here like a hundred
ninety pounds and you hit him flush
you're gonna smash them so as you become
a super athlete it's really easy to rely
on things that work to go down these
other paths to stop developing yourself
to stop on these journeys of exploration
that really make you you know invincible
or unreadable or a master an expert in
your field that's the hardest part I
want to go do what's best and easy and
fun
knock people out and but the truth is I
suck at some things and those are all
the stuff that is like it should be the
study but I should be the focus of the
whole moment mmm because when you get
there you're not ready then you're gonna
freak out and lose energy and focus and
you know then the Machine everything
falls apart
right but ultimately that's what you I
mean that's what you have to do to grow
right yeah as a human being you don't
want we don't want to you know you know
we want to take the fat pill we want to
take the easy you don't we don't people
don't want to get pushed in a wall and
punched in the head to figure out
something that's I don't wait too much
yeah give me the gun to the head I'm
done I'm out of here like I've been
punched in the head since like seventh
grade so all right so you go on to be
you go on this crazy winning streak
fighter of the decade you fight from 94
to like 2010 right um essentially
undefeated you have a couple there was a
couple times where you didn't only ten
years on ten years undefeated
and ultimately you you retire in 2010
after certain 80s or Nick do you miss
Nick yeah no there but a good woman
Tommy
but he's are like the next generation
coming up right yeah and then you had
one fight like a year ago right
well the grappling match a gravid
grappling yet why did you come back and
do that it was totally like left field
uh-huh you know I had I but when I was
16 I had this my right leg went numb
sort of dragging behind me and I went to
the doctor and they said listen you got
a spawned aletheia osis in your l3 so
you need spinal surgery and I was in a
group home at the time so I was like I
want to do with this and my group home
doctor dad took me to a chiropractor and
he's like listen it's a common injury
but you're gonna have to care for it the
rest of your life like you're gonna keep
the muscle built and you got to do these
goofy exercises so gives me these goofy
exercise but I do them for 30 years and
then it stops working and I have the
worst back pain you could ever imagine
and I'm considering surgery and I'm like
mr. natural like I'm not into anything
cutting my body open so you know I'm
going down this deep
of surgery and and finally I consult
with one of my friends like he got to
see my friend Dennis
he's like a magic man and I go and see
him in like an hour he fixed my back
he's like what's wrong with you and I go
what's wrong with me if I could I ask
him all about it and it's like listen
you're putting too much energy into it
he's like you you know you just need new
exercise your body's changed
everything's changed things like let me
restructure you let me give you these
new exercise and send you on your way
and within two weeks I'm like climbing
mountains and kick playing and kickball
tournaments and all the stuff that I
wanted to be doing but I was in too much
pain to be doing you know for like three
or four years I'm doing and I'm like
this is amazing and so I'm putting out
in the universe that I want to do stuff
with my body and brain phone rings is
Japanese promotion they're like is there
any way you could wrestle Sakuraba who's
my oldest nemesis like for 18 years you
know at this date and I'm like maybe
like I just tell him a story I'm like I
just fix my back and like I'm so fired
up about it and and I go let me go to
the gym and try it out and I go in two
three days later I call him back and I
go I could probably do this like it will
go have to modify the rules a little bit
cuz I don't it's not good but I think I
could do this and I wasn't so you when
did it it was draw right it's a drug
yeah yeah ten minutes drive yeah that's
cool though so you were 45 45 45 right
so you're 47 now 40 seems till 45 you're
still 45 and 46 what do you say ha ha
all right well this is super interesting
to me because I have spondee also yeah
and it hurts right Mapei niz not that
bad
I was first diagnosed with it maybe in
2010 or something like that and I'm 51
right now but I was in the midst of like
training really hard and I was like I
didn't have any pain at the time and I
was like and it was a chiropractor who
diagnosed it and I would go to him and I
still go to him and I get traction and
you know he adjusts me and things like
that but then at this year 51 is like
the first year where I've started to
really feel my mortality in a way that I
haven't I have a little bit I have some
pain on the left side like sciatic nerve
pain
a little bit of numbness on the top of
my left foot and uh and I'm looking for
some new and different things to do so
I'm really interested in what Dennis had
yeah you see Dennis yeah yeah out here
yeah he's in Beverly Hills oh he is yeah
tell me wouldn't ya hooked me I want to
tell me tell me what uh what some of the
things he was instructing you to do well
um he said one of the my core things is
just as you know instability you know
there's it's not connected so it's not
all structured so it's over fatiguing
all the time so when I went in I was
pretty asked out like I was my back had
gone out bad I think I was at all these
appearances lined up and I couldn't I
couldn't get off the I could go off the
ground it was first time my daughter had
seen me like that yeah so I was like now
so and he's basically like listen you
know you've built all these muscles to
support you
with the crooked thing mmm it's like we
gotta release all that stuff right kind
of restructure Yuri rebalance you and
then he's like let me show you you know
it's like you just gotta get that tiny
tiny muscle on top of your you know
right on top of your hip it's like you
just got to get to that muscle and like
let me show you how to do it so is it
like a lot of so as type stretching to
lengthen out the well would I for me
it's about keeping my hips square and
strong so I do basic you know warrior
poses and postures and you know lunge
dances and stuff like that to keep
everything aligned mm-hmm but literally
for me I just need to keep that little
tiny muscle that sits above your your
hip bone in the back right I just need
to keep that strong mm-hmm because it's
not because of the misconnection right
so if I keep that strong everything else
feels great if I skip three days I
literally feel like my back's gonna go
out I don't feel like I'm gonna lose a
thing here and it's gonna pinch and my
right legs gonna go no yeah so you have
no numbness now no I got nothing that's
great but if I miss like I laid on the
couch for two days I was so tired from
the yard work and it instantly today
just pain and I got tingles in my in my
leg right but what I'll do is he showed
me the exercise to unlock it to help
release the pressure on it uh-huh
and so like I get on a table I'll
getting like a sprinter stance and I'll
like try to pull my heel back and really
my hip you know that to stretch out yeah
yeah yeah and that will that will take
the pressure off and kind of release it
if I have it go out and I get like this
I'm like mm-hmm
we're a team right yeah you're all like
lopsided and and I think you know for me
just running for so many years and yeah
running is a tough line because at the
end yeah well it create yeah and you
develop certain muscles and others
atrophy and you get that imbalance and
and then when with the spondee you start
favoring one side over the other and
yeah that leads to running injuries
there's a whole trans gating effect he
he spent an hour releasing the rest of
my body tension which was two other guys
with a couple of machines and some other
weird stuff and I thought at one point
is gonna tear my knee out and I was
gonna crap on myself but every three
minutes you'd be like stand up already
let me look at you all right get back
down let's adjust this side cuz every
time he'd figure out where the tensions
left until there was no tension left
he's like okay you're straight they've
got no more attention and he's like now
keep that area strong and you're
straight you're great so how long did
you have to kind of do this protocol
before the pain alleviated instant
really instant no it was you understand
I was laid over like trying to explain
to my daughter no I'm gonna be okay
you should never see me like that so
it's been nine years you know or at
least five years that she's never seen
me this well uh yeah right no you know
I'm crawling around the house sometimes
we don't touch me like jacked so it was
just a big wake-up call I say what am i
doing either I'm gonna get this fixed or
I'm gonna figure out an alternative yeah
and he just happened happy I'll turn
into so yeah you hundred-percent gotta
go see him cool so you feel good now
yeah you think you'll ever you'll you'll
do another fight no no no I didn't enjoy
it yeah I mean I enjoyed the competitive
side but I didn't enjoy the training and
then it was last minute you know I was
like the fill-in last-minute guy so
there was just it wasn't the experience
that I wanted although it was experience
that I wanted well hey what did you want
what did you think that you wanted I
just wanted enough time I got wanted to
really train yeah I wanted you know you
know for weeks you know like I wanted a
real try
session some old you know I don't train
I hiked slowly and I do yoga and you
know I danced at gala is like training
is very minimal now mmm so let's talk
about now you're doing all kinds of
things now but you know probably it is
the main thing that you're doing kind of
mentoring and coaching other people not
not just in MMA but kind of like life
coaching right yeah yeah I mean uh I
don't actually have any people in MMA
except for a few or one mm a company
owner mm-hmm
but yeah it's mainly business stuff
right I am I at the last phase of my
career that have been the Strikeforce
era which would have been the last five
years so 2005 to 2010 I became a league
owner and you know I was the broadcaster
I was the consultant that was really
ahead of the strike force brand and I
was also like the main event guy so what
I did to kind of get the tools to do
that because I mean it's ridiculous like
I was trying to lead this whole league
against the UFC and and get on network
television as I took a mentor and he had
learned he was 35 years into product
development and asset management and
mechanics in Silicon Valley so he's like
a product product a product he really
taught me how to look at products and
businesses and IPS and lifespans and he
just taught me about business I didn't
know what business I went to college in
prison University of Louisville I didn't
get a solid one so this was another
level of education and you know by that
time I had a brand worth I'd like five
million dollars or something and and I
was just entering into a phase of you
know huge opportunity and and that was
ownership in the league and these other
roles and stuff and so I just in the
midst of training and doing all the
stuff I was doing I was like why I
learned this stuff too and I went down I
went down that journey and for three and
a half years I took an education on how
to asset management project development
product development and then at the same
time I was running a professional
fighting team right
and it's all just become now one unit
except for nobody's fighting each other
professionally we're all just business
professionals so what's going on with
Strikeforce now we sold it to the UFC
yeah we made it made a super nice exit
uh-huh yeah and so all right so now
you've you've taken this acumen that you
developed as a result of that experience
that play sort of that's the plus and
the plus minus equal right like yeah
working with that guy in Silicon Valley
who taught you all of these things and
so what is the when you take somebody on
to to mentor them in the capacity that
you do like what does that look like
like walk me through that experience
well everyone's at a different place
normally but most people are obviously
looking for something some change some
moment some divination so usually
they're coming in search of something I
the hardest part is finding out what
they want what they're looking for
although they'll tell you hey ears what
I want to do or I would imagine they're
stuck often everyone yeah usually
usually you're stuck and you're like
what do I do and you don't know how to
change or transform or make that make
that movement so usually I get that I
did them in some role or get them there
and then I sit down with them I figure
out what their roles and goals are like
what do they really want to do because
we all talked about stuff and we're all
doing stuff but do we really want to do
it like is it really what we want to be
doing and then once I can figure out
what they really want to do you know
then I can kind of help guide them and
and pull out of them what what that
dream is I guess what that thing is you
know what what they really really truly
want to do what their purpose or what
they believe their purpose is and what
do you think it is about your unique
experience that that makes like your
your tutelage your counsel a little bit
different than what somebody else might
somebody might get from you know I don't
know Tony Robbins or somebody else who
kind of is in that space uh I I mean I
don't know to be honest with you mhm
I just I can feel what people and people
tell me what they need and then for some
reason I can help
visualize and create systems to capture
that and yeah people trust me I think
because of my honesty you both in my
story and you know I live this is my
life like it's what I write I think Tony
and I just I think Tony Robbins and I
show you that like I think he came from
a place of you know wow we could help
some people like this is important you
know we shouldn't let people do or live
like this or experience this cuz it
sucks but most people either don't know
what they want or think they know what
they want exactly what they want but
here's the thing they don't really truly
know what they want if they sit down and
think about it yeah and we don't sit
down and think about well because we're
living right we're living we're yeah
we're scared
we still world and we're and because
we're scared we're living reflexively
yeah and the devil we know is better
than the devil we don't yes and we're
taught to and we're raised to seek
comfort and luxury and security and
these things are impediments to the
things that we really want in life and
also the things that truly will make us
happy because it's not about those other
things yeah so the process of getting
somebody to that place like requires
them to be well I think it goes back to
trust like they have to trust you they
have to feel comfortable with you and
and you have to create that space that
allows them to be vulnerable so that
they can tell you what those fears are
right I mean yeah that seems to be the
only way to kind of at least address it
so that you can move beyond it yeah yeah
and it for some reason I mean I see it
because when I read my story I'm like
what on earth yeah this is the most
ridiculous stuff that you can imagine
but I have all those experiences every
single one you know including people
like well how do you know what business
I was like well my first business
experiences I would get hired to set at
the end of a table at a multi-billion
dollar negotiations by billionaires
uh-huh so at some point they could be
like yep Frank Shamrock right here to
chair University Leavenworth it was it
nothing else just to name me and to show
that I was there but I was sitting there
as a young man going home all right
is how business is done this is
intriguing and learning about business
and that was you know how I now
understand well wait a minute
this is what business is about and this
is how it's done and you know these are
a lot of the principles that are
followed at the highest level of
business right your story is about pain
and determination and self
responsibility these are things that a
lot of people you know like there aren't
that many people who have had to
confront the kind of obstacles in pain
that you had to and I think most people
really just aren't that disciplined
right they they didn't go to a dojo in
Japan they didn't have the the the you
know hard knock experience that you had
growing up and they also didn't have the
kind of structure that you were lucky
enough to find yourself in later so how
do you how do you convey to these people
the lessons that you learned in a way
that they can hear it and then implement
it well I believe everyone can yeah the
only did the only thing I did was change
my mind
mm-hmm like that's it I went wow I can't
do the second I screwed up yeah like I
just changed who I what I truly believed
about myself I went wow I'm I'm I am a
criminal and a liar and a scumbag like
all that stuff they wrote it I'm truly
that person and I'm gonna change it like
that was it mm-hmm and I think most
people don't ever sit down and write
that down I you know I've done a lot of
good things I've done a lot of bad
things it's like I think when you face
them and you move through them I think
when you're prepared to address them I
call it the secret life everybody has
you know the life they live out here and
then everyone has the life they live
inside right and when you not like say
yeah that life that they live inside is
is often marked by fears we talked about
but also shame it's inside because
they're afraid if they ever told anyone
about that they would lose all their
friends and all that sort of thing so I
know in my own life experience like you
have to own that and you have to you
know in order to move past it you have
to shed a light on it and that involves
talking to
like yourself or confiding in another as
a process of dismantling it so that you
can grow and transcend it yeah and even
just addressing it for a lot of people
it's writing it down and going wow yeah
double underline Wow yeah I mean I'm a
long time in recovery and that's the
they call that in 12-step to inventory
yeah yeah even for the Brailey if you
try to learn something you know there's
a million ways to learn but the minute
you write it down the minute your brain
connects with the mechanics of creating
and writing it is so imprinted and it
has so much value to your brain and
that's why I write it even talked about
writing it's like when you can write
when you can document when you can note
when you can theorize it's like that's
the stuff where your brain is going and
growing and and changing and and that's
the stuff you want to support right you
know heart is sit down right I'm a loser
I'm a criminal I'm the worst father ever
like I'm just like my dad you know I'm
really am those people like that's
really hard and then to make a change so
that like but why not I mean like why
not well I think there's there's the
stories we tell ourselves about
ourselves and there's the facts of our
experience but some people become overly
connected to these stories like they get
attached to well I'm a lousy dad and I'm
of this and I'm of that and becomes a
self-perpetuating cycle right it may be
the truth but it also becomes a pretty
accurate predictor of future behavior so
I think the trick is once you're writing
it down and you're you're honest with
yourself about that how do you interrupt
that cycle right yeah it's not easy it's
not easy that's where your community
comes in and your plusses and your
minuses and well let's talk about people
we even talked about the plus/minus
equal thing we didn't actually describe
exactly yeah yeah we kind of it's it to
me it's just it's how I live my life you
know it's it's the system that I
function on and
for anything I want to accomplish I find
that plus someone has done it someone
has accomplished it somebody's
successful and it's someone who's happy
doing it whatever it is and I you know I
present myself then I make myself humble
I try to learn from them and sometimes
they say no yeah and then I find my
equal you know my competitor my neighbor
my friend my whatever the person I want
to equal my business to or equal my
presentation to or my thing to and I
find out what they're doing and I
befriend them or I embattled them or I
I somehow become aware of them and then
I find a - I find somebody to teach
somebody to guide somebody take my
pluses information my equals information
and empower them with and I just worked
that system on everything I do from
marriage to business to you know make a
film you know start a PSA I'm doing a
PSA I'm gonna do a PSA you know what I
called him a guy who's done 500 PSA
someone like buddy here's what I need
what are you doing a PSA on on Mental
Health Awareness hmm but when I was
fired you to do that
one of my clients in my talent
management business is bipolar they were
my best friends and and I met him in
broadcasting and he's just one of the
best broadcasters in the business but
he's bipolar you know he's up he's down
he's crazy he's locked up he's not he's
you know we're looking for medication
it's been you know a ten year journey
with him and I just met him and you know
no one was caring for him was like will
do we can't leave this guy behind we got
to bring him with us and he's been super
successful but you know part of his
journey is is is becoming a you know so
uh as social activists and communicating
you know what he's doing and and how
he's doing it you know I've seen him I
mean he's he's manic well yeah anybody
who's had any experience with somebody
with bipolar I mean it's a roller
coaster ride yeah it's tough
there's a lot of you know education that
needs to be done not just for those who
suffer but for you know everybody out
there to kind of understand what that
condition is all about because we
demonize it in a way that I don't think
it's fair know now in the challenging
because another
have celebrated you know in other
cultures it's it's it's at least
recognized as being different mmm to me
they're just different he's different my
buddy's different yeah he's amazing but
he's different ya know and it's like we
gotta do different things for him but
with those different things and with you
know some nice lifestyle adjustments I
mean he's extraordinary he's killing it
mm-hmm
you know part of our PSA campaign is we
have this stigma around mental health
and people are like they turn their back
you know they don't turn and go what do
you mean yeah you know and hey I've got
those calls at 3:00 a.m. and 4:00 a.m.
5:00 a.m. and you know I mean this guy
I've got those crazy calls but you know
at the same time he's just different and
if he had another disease or another
illness we wouldn't think twice about it
mm-hmm you know we'd be there supporting
him before I am or 3:00 a.m. you know we
begin his medicine at 5:00 a.m. yeah but
because he's a little quirky we're like
ah you know goofball you seem like such
a sweet guy of such I'm picturing you
beating the hell out of this is the most
challenging part I love this so I had
the hardest time hurting people uh-huh I
could really truly wait on me and I
couldn't understand where it came from
so I'm actually my first professional
fight you know no rules fight I lost it
because I couldn't put the hammer down I
couldn't break the leg I couldn't break
the arm you know I couldn't I couldn't
kill him like I was like ah this is not
you know this is not in my soul you know
even though that was my dream yeah so I
had to leave that thing lose it on that
and sit down with myself again and go
wait a minute
I picked up a sword I'm swinging it in
battle and I'm not gonna you know down
anybody and they're gonna down me yeah
I'm like what if this is the craziest
thing in the world and what I realized I
was just traumatized you know the
experience of abuse and all the stuff
and the fear I was just traumatized by
the violence and I hadn't accepted what
it truly was and I hadn't accepted that
that was my my real role I was gonna
hurt people mm-hmm how was my job and
once I did I was like well you know this
is really messed up but yeah
yeah I have to hurt people that's my job
yeah and then I got really good at it
a lot of people got messed up well uh
yeah but now it doesn't it doesn't seem
like it's your nature though you know
and and like I said at the outset i'm
princeton mac danzig and i have the same
thing with him I'm like he's such a nice
guy like and then I watched him fight
and I'm like who is that guy you're like
I was like whoa that's what he does like
I I can't even imagine you know and I
think I think that's something in that
that's something I would imagine is kind
of across the board with the best
fighters like they they're working out
their angst and their frustration and
their aggression and all of that in the
training and in the fighting and when
they're walking around in their life
they're cool you know and it's it's the
guy with the you know Tapout t-shirt and
the hello he was like thinks he's all
that you know who's like aggressive I'm
like no the real fighters aren't like
that yeah you know yeah they get their
fill mm-hmm so they don't need to cool
well we gonna wrap this up here in a
minute but I thought it would be cool to
kind of leave people with some some
insight perhaps a little inspiration or
some tools for somebody who is in that
place of a fear or living reflexively
and is not happy and perhaps can't see
their way out to the next thing or is
disconnected from what it is that they
really want to do or the person that
they really want to be and as somebody
who has overcome so much and and it's
living such a huge life in so many
different ways now you know what kind of
you know what would you impart to that
person I would start with looking inside
and writing it down and for a lot of
still do that by the way every day so
it's still so what's your what's your
tactical process um
I start every day when I wake and I come
to consciousness I instantly begin my
prayers mm-hmm and I thank God for
waking me up once again and and and the
day and
and then I go into anything I think is
important to talk to God about it in the
universe and then I and then I meditate
and I visualize what I want my day to
look like mmm and that's before I get
out of bed every single day yeah and
then that you're you you seem like
you're a really good at visualization
yeah I can see this stuff but it's
because what what I put in my brain is
the stuff and nothing else
mm-hmm and I think that's where people
go astray is they put all this other
crap in their brain when if they really
truly want something that's the only
thing that should be in their brain
mm-hmm that's all you really need yeah
that's what make you happy that's your
dream I don't think we're selective
enough with what we allow through that
sieve you know especially with our
mobile devices we're just we're
polluting ourselves with a lot of
content but not a lot of intentionality
about what that is and what is what it's
actually doing to us Yentl II
emotionally and spiritually
yeah wears out your wears out your
spirit and your soul but if you want to
change it oh yeah there's turning stuff
off and getting yourself and take some
time and meditate and you know the best
meditation is when you can add something
physical to it you know we can create
some martial you know rowing swimming
you know something where you're really
connected and if you can add the earth
or the universe like we can add
something of substance to it like it
just gets you know better and better but
it's in those moments you know where
you're in your brain and you're really
pushing and you're in other settings you
know that you go ah oh yeah that's right
these are my dreams and then write those
down and then find the people find the
community and tell them do the
plus/minus equal yeah and tell somebody
here's what here's what most people are
afraid to do is to tell somebody I'll
tell you all my dreams because I'm
actively pursuing them and crushing them
and if I don't we're gonna celebrate in
the loss or the change or the whatever
most people never go here's my dream
because they're afraid it's not going to
come true right well once they do that
then they're on the hook and then they
don't know they can't back out yeah but
I say it own it write it start it get to
plus minus equal live by honor respect
and discipline be a good
person and all of this stuff will happen
for you because people will will like
you they're gonna be pleased with you
they'll be pleased to be around you and
to help you I'm with you Frank Shamrock
not one thing to that though which is
patience ya gotta be patient meditation
and journaling have been instrumental in
my own life and I began I began
journaling I was using the artists way
like right when I got out of rehab in
1998 and I continued to do it to this
day and I remember doing morning pages
journaling every single day for a long
time just confused you know but it was a
way of expressing that confusion and I
think it was necessary to get to a place
of eventual clarity but patience is
super important and I think especially
particularly important in our you know
quick fix life hack culture where
everybody wants to snap their fingers
and make it happen overnight so patience
and I think you know if you're an
example of anything it's it's that you
know we all are capable of so much more
than we allow ourselves to believe and
if you're willing to do the work and be
patient and show up and give all of
yourself to something whatever it is
that amazing things can happen so thank
you my pleasure yeah cool man great to
talk to you
awesome so if you want to connect with
Frank the best place to do that I mean
you got website Twitter all that Frank
Shamrock yeah I am at Frank Shamrock
everywhere
and yeah if you haven't asked you can
send to ask Frank at Frank Shamrock calm
cool and I'll try to fill your ask if I
can't yeah I'll let you know again yeah
and pick up his book on cage ah yeah I
saw to read I haven't read it yet you're
gonna love it
honestly I've read you know book nerd I
read every of it I read a thousand
biographies so when I wrote one I was
like no I'm gonna write the real deal
yeah like no fluff no and like I'm gonna
write what really truly happened so well
most sports biographies suck Lisa
and they're nervous they're trying to
advance these guys a brand of somebody
who's in the twilight of their career
like I hang out with them like no dude
this didn't happen so I wrote it and I
was saying okay
I remember reading all those books as a
young man and thinking that's what it's
like and I went I want to write a book
so that they know that's what it's like
for real yeah so that's what I wrote a
book for that kid you know a young man
who you know is on a journey mm-hmm
hopefully like we're all on a journey I
know all right and hopefully just
continues on and on that's the blessing
it's a blessing cool great talking to
you thanks thanks Bob please
[Music]